joining us now for reaction just outside
of the Washington DC is he's at CPAC
Nigel Farage Fox News contributor and
former UK Independence Party leader
all right Nigel you're there at CPAC
with all those activists and with the
president talked about the judges today
in his speech and how if we don't keep
this momentum going you know we won't
get judges on the courts and a lot of
his agenda can be undone what was your
sense from the President's speech well
of course it's all about the midterms
isn't it really I mean he's achieved
amazing things he said today that he
kept more promises than it actually made
during the election campaign which was a
great line but he's doing his stuff he
got tax reform through just before
Christmas very very important but he
needs to make sure that he keeps
majorities in both of those houses in
the midterms so how does he keep the
Trump revolution rolling well I tell you
something I shared a platform with him
in Mississippi back in the presidential
campaign he went around the country
speaking the big audiences he's a
wonderful motivator but what I saw today
was a president in a different gear a
president who was using humor a
president who was light a president who
even told a joke against himself about
his own bald patch and I think if Trump
goes around the country in the run-up to
these midterms and performs anything
like he did today at CPAC he will keep
this momentum going and that'll lead
through to everything he needs to do
Nigel you and I ran into each other this
morning and you
nice enough to agree to come on the show
tonight it was so awesome but it was
right but it was right before the
president spoke I spoke at around 9
o'clock and what I was trying to do and
I know you said this as well you had
such a great speech that we need to be
happy warriors we're winning on all
these big issues the left is resistant
this hold our conservative you know
Hangul kind of approach it's tedious
nobody wants to be on that ride look
career politicians are as dull as
ditchwater why they're always being
saved they don't want to take a risk all
they care about is getting reelected
they're not doing this at a passion
belief in country patriotism caring
about ordinary people they are dull they
are humorless they are without any real
personality and what Sparkle today from
the president was him being him and I
was very very privileged Laura to meet
you this morning but I was also very
privileged to meet the president just
after he came off stage and I saw a man
there you know absolutely at the top of
his game I get the feeling that this
president is now really enjoying what
he's doing you're seeing is his real
personality coming out and I have to say
my view my view and I've watched this
and I followed this and I've been part
of this even though I'm a foreigner but
my view is with Trump the best is yet to
come
I mean he referred to the next seven
years clearly putting the putting to
rest these ideas he's not going to run
for re-election I want to play for you
the media's reaction to the president's
hour-plus long speech let's watch
this morning at CPAC he covered at least
31 different topics in an hour and 15
minute speech but it took almost 40
minutes before the president began his
conversation on the Parkland school
shooting President Trump made time in
his CPAC speech today to address his
bald spot yet nothing on Russian
election meddling both at CPAC and at
his news conference he conveniently
avoided talk of his new tougher position
on guns I mean the president was
self-deprecating which the media had
complained he never was i fouled we're
watching it in our hotel room we were
all screaming my producer said we were
just screaming it was so funny and it
lightened the mood but they literally
can never say anything positive doesn't
matter what he does even if he pushes
some gun control measures they say it's
not enough it's unbelievable
no of course they don't and you remember
with Ronald Reagan it was exactly the
same they never ever forgave Reagan for
winning once and then twice and they
kept at him all the way through his
presidency but you know what he goes
down in history as one of the great
presidents and I don't think it masses
anymore right CNN say or the New York
Times right it doesn't matter the world
has changed
you know people out there all rifo
decent ordinary people who live their
lives do their jobs pay their taxes obey
the laws bring up their families they
don't care anymore what mainstream media
is telling us yeah you know what they
make they make up their own minds I
think you're right the progress has left
them behind and it's almost not so it's
not worth engaging with them or getting
demoralize or distracted by what they're
saying or the constant resistance move
the ball down the field get great
legislation passed do the stuff that
he's already done and then some I want
to show a poll on screen u.s.
satisfaction with world standing hits
13-year high 45% positive rating 2017 it
was 32%
2005 it was 48% that's the Gallup poll
so Nigel my question to you is how are
how are we being viewed do you sense
internationally Americans are happy with
how they think we're being viewed by the
rest of the world under Trump at least
it's gone up it's not still not a
majority but that's good news
considering where they predicted he was
going to take us well let's be fair
Obama was a disaster America standing in
the world went down considerably during
the eight year period and everyone said
the Trump on the world stage would be an
embarrassment he'd be a dummy
he wouldn't know how to behave and you
know what right from that Riyadh speech
his first speech through the Davos
reason that he delivered the line you
know America first but America's not
alone did it beautifully and people
understood it all the way through he is
behaved on the international stage with
huge dignity with great confidence in
fact when he was in Beijing walking
around I thought he was about a but a
bid in to buy the place that would be
nice yeah we need that to happen we
don't even have time to get into the
China thing but he's finally he's he's
actually the first president to address
the China threat in a substantive way on
trade and not afraid to say so Nigel
which is fantastic Nigel thank you thank
you so much for joining us we got a roll
but have a great time it's great to see
you today and fantastic speech